Turns out, we're all using a can opener wrong.
How should we be...
That's that's what I hear.
So basically, I mean, I've been using it
kind of like this,
but I think most people do
like they put the can opener on the top
but apparently you're supposed to put it on the side.
All right. We're gonna watch a video
that corroborates your story.
This is how we used to do it.
So you're gonna hold it like this,
so the blade is gonna be on the outside
and then it's gonna click
and you're just gonna twist it all the way around
and watch how easily it just comes off.
And it comes off attached to the can opener like this.
Oh, that does,
at first I was like, yeah potato patato
do it whatever way you want
but the whole snapping of the lid coming off. Right?
Like it just, okay.
Mine works, look,
that's actually pretty good.
I have to say.
I have not.
And I don't,
I didn't do it like this.
Okay. My can opener is not working.
Hold on a second.
All right.
Wait, what?
(audience laughing)
Just throw it against the wall. (laughs)
Okay. I can tell you what I'm not gonna be doing.
I'm going back to my old fashioned way.
Alright, next.
Do we have a specific way to use a strainer?
This I'm intrigued by because I'm a big strainer.
I'm always boiling pastas and stuff.
So apparently this is the easiest way now to do this.
I haven't seen this.
I'm watching it for the first time.
Go, roll the tape.
Show me the life hack
that you randomly saw one day
that is now an unconscious standard practice in your life.
I'll go first.
Oh yeah.
I've never done it that way. Bobby?
I'm not into it.
I do it like everybody else does it.
I would just put it in the sink
and I would just pour the water into the strainer.
And the reason why I liked that
is because I can see where the hot water is going.
Don't forget a lot of times
this water is really piping hot.
Once you cover it and you start spilling up the water,
there is a possibility, I think,
that the hot water can go places
that you don't want it to go.
And I can't really see the hot water coming out
from under the strainer.
I'm gonna try it.
Just in case.
I just don't like it.
I wanna see where my hot water is going all the time.
Now my straining upside down when a heck of a lot better
than my can opening situation.
So I'm not hating the strainer
half as much as I hate that darn can opener situation. So...
All right, well, I'm sort of the opposite.
I'm kind of into the can opener,
but I'm not into the strainer.
So like we eat 50-50 on that, but opposite.
Opposites attract, to each his own.
We picked up something new today on TikTOK.
And I have to say, I am loving TikTok.
It's like, they're just reinventing hacks
and tips about life.
Everyone's expressing themselves.
So I enjoy TikTok and I'm glad...
Yeah I do to.
It's very fun.
It's educational.
It's teaching us fun stuff.
Okay. We must do this again.
Bobby, I can't thank you enough
and Nacho, if I may whisper in your ear,
thank you for taking care of all these rescue kitties
and giving them so much food
and providing for them and being such a philanthropic kitty.
Okay. Now keep an eye on our website for Nacho's interview
for our digital series, "Pause for Paws"
'cause that's coming soon
and that's gonna be amazing.
I mean, look at,
come on, Nacho you are so handsome.
I'm just gonna say,
I was gonna say,
you get on that kitty Tinder.
And you swipe right.
I think it's a match.
I think it's a match, indeed.
Thank you, Bobby so much.
We'll be right back.
(audience applauding)
(bright music)